you
foreign
you kids be careful now my eric
certainly has a lot of little playmates
he's such a friendly
and struck him boy in the head with his
hammer that monster is sitting right
over there
this is the king's room i don't think
we're supposed to be in here
what exactly are you looking for
i refuse to be your gynecologist
oh
dinner
these lands hold many dangers new kid
yeah you move to the wrong realm
nice hair douchebag
in your face
this looks like a job for paladin
butters
i got your back yo that beat i better
way to turn before i do any more healing
i have to go to the bathroom
hey look you're bleeding
it looks bad here take some of this
magic cure potion
make sure you always carry a few potions
just don't get grounded for raiding the
apothecary's pantry like i did
we're still doing this right
ah
yeah that's it little buddy
oh [ __ ]
sweet
there you go
man i could be watching tv right now
your glue
stop [ __ ] around
you think we were too hard on them
sorry but we can't be friends until you
have more friends
i'm actually faster at facebook
messaging speaking
here this will just go a lot faster if i
there's some weirdo hanging out at the
public storage i'm not going back there
we must get back to the quested hand my
lord
are you hey that means you don't know
anything about me huh
you looking for craig well he can't play
he's in detention
something about flipping off the
principal we better get to the other
guys first
one
well well
well hey officer but baby that's butt
brady wait
i'll be watching you new kid on facebook
i hope you post a lot of
fat pictures
this here is the marketplace this is
where heroes can come for adventuring
gear nose jabs
and abortions
live
this movie is really sweet too bad you
guys can't see it
hey over here
welcome to tweet coffee coffee made with
ingredients supplied by local organic
suppliers
it's local coffee brewed locally twig
twig have you picked up the fresh
not local dad i'm still trying to do all
my chores well hurry up son the family
business is relying on you
you should try some coffee it gives you
that edge you need to stay focused at
school
hey big nose you should consider having
someone
what's this huh now the guys need me now
oh there's no we mean
it's way too much to do how am i
supposed to do all this
wait you could you go get the far clock
delivery for me
if you do i can finish here and then and
then i'll still have time to play please
would you it's a kenny's house like
always you give them this
they'll give you the delivery
how am i supposed to do all of this
there's no way man starbucks has like
eight employees
here it's just me yeah
mhm
hey over here are you okay you want to
see a movie oh that's right you can't
because you swear to die and it's too
mature for you
cheese
what oh this isn't for me this is for
the nice people who are renting the
guest house out in the back
yeah yeah we got the package for tweet
hey that's not the usual kid that picks
up the package
huh oh [ __ ] it's a camp
i've killed way bigger guys than you
well the new kid has
ain't got all day pig
are you gonna arrest me or what
that was the most perfect throw i've
ever seen
here
oh
red
i got your back yo
two battles
are you gonna arrest me or what
oh
there you go
taste bad justice
this cop's crazy
uh these witch doctors must be cooking
up a secret potion i wonder if it's a
healing potion
what's
what
you have to prove your mercury
you did it you got the pick up oh thanks
man dad i finished my work can i go play
where's today's delivery right here
hmm yep that's good [ __ ] all right tweak
you can play for a little bit
but be home before dark or you'll be
grounded grounded like the fresh grinds
of our all organic tweak land
made with ingredients from local
tweakers thanks kid i gotta go get
changed and then i'll be you at the
kingdom
hey over here i don't feel to totally
not be able to heal any cherishing
fill-up movie
this is
if you try again i will pepper spray you
back to the stone age
you looking for a fight some kids gave
me the worst pink belly over there
out of my way stan one time gave me the
grossest wet wheelie right here
ah
well hello there jimbo and ned well what
brings you here today
business or pleasure or vengeance
vengeance
you've come to the right place howdy
there haven't seen you before
you must be the new kid that moved to
town and you're into hunting huh
well but boy you've come to the right
place south park is chock full of things
to shoot that would delight any
taxidermist survivalist or weekend
animal death enthusiast
ain't much i can sell to a minor thanks
to the stupid democrats but but if you
could prove yourself a real hunter i
might be able to get you some better
stuff
you should buy a copy of the hunter's
guide to south park wildlife
this book thingy here
i what the [ __ ]
oh no
phyllis we can work this out
i'm sorry
ow
move along boy this is neato huh
can i help you
what's this oh the elves took the stick
again hang on a second
thank you for thy message traveler i
shall make haste to koopa keep
mom can you drive me to eric's house
i got a beating with your name on it
oh
little soldiers reporting for duty grand
wizard
nice work douchebag now all my men are
here and ready to fight for it wait a
minute
where's feldspar where's my level 12
thief hey
hey yeah where's craig he's in detention
what
he flipped off the principal so he's in
detention again oh my god
if they've locked away our thief in
detention we have no hope of getting
back the stick of truth
we have to break him out ah no way man
last time we broke craig out of
detention we all got in trouble
getting into trouble is a risk that
douchebag is willing to take you have to
break our thief douchebag
but don't worry i will not let you go
unprepared i'm going to teach you how to
use magic
meet me at the training barracks it's
time for you to learn
dragon shout
you fight well douchebag but to truly
succeed in combat you must learn to
harness the power
of your farts farting on an opponent at
precisely the right time is key to
battle i shall show you how it's done
but first
you must take the gentleman's oath you
must promise to never
ever fart on anyone's bow okay farting
on an opponent necessary but farting on
someone's bows is not cool
do you understand all right then let's
begin your training
to conjure dragon shout you must first
clear your mind and take in a deep
breath
through your butthole like so
then let it rumble inside you and drag
it down
show you one more time suck it in let it
rumble
dragon now you ready
dragon shout find the frequency
don't be polite dude just let it rip
i'll show you one more time
suck it in let it rumble dragon
now you ready dragon shout
find the frequency hold hold
my god that was incredible a man could
live a hundred years and never again
witness a spell so
boisterous could it be that the
prophecies are true could it be that the
dragon bone has come at last
in our hour of need now let us try your
skill on a real opponent
hey hey princess skinny could you come
here
okay just do real quick princess candy
sir juice bag wants to show you
something
all right you two spa sir douchebag show
princess kenny the magical powers i've
taught you
that was [ __ ] hilarious dude that was
[ __ ] odd
oh okay good job sir douchebag that was
sweet thanks princess skinny
that's all for now cool
okay but dude seriously remember don't
ever do that on someone's balls okay
seriously
you have master dragon shouts from now
on it will be easier for you
kenny will assist you on your quest
douchebag now go get craig while i rest
and relax upon my throne
foreign
one point
but
so
here's what we're selling today
a nice purchase what are you telling
how may i be of service you name it
we'll sell it
got some pretty good work here
good choice
all yours how may i be of service
here's what we're showing today
foreign
how may i be of service you name it
we'll sell it
got something to win to sell
sound up sergeant
some more
oh
one time i got the worst milky behind
that building over there it sucked
sorry i've already got friends
craig craig this is detention okay
stop looking at your watch because
you're here for three hours buddy
okay whatever now don't think your
friends are gonna come
bust you out this time craig my name is
feldspar and i'm a level six thief and
the humans will soon rescue me from this
tower
no your name is [ __ ] craig tucker and
you're in detention now start doing your
homework okay i've got all the doors
sealed
and i've got hallway monitors working
overtime nobody's gonna save your ass
today craig okay
so
excuse me but school is out and no
students allowed on the premises until
tomorrow at 7 30 am
you are going to school on
uh hamburgers
let's see what you've got
works i know valance doesn't solve
anything but i kind of like it
officer down officer down send back up
i repeat officer down all hallway
monitors to the right hallway
oh god damn it here they come
they're gonna get you craig you're not
getting out of detention
i'll be out of here in ten minutes
careful douchebag this dungeon holds
many secrets
for centuries these halls went
unmonitored but then the evil overlord
mackie rose an army of gingers to
protect his precious after-school
detention
now these minions lurk the halls
terrorizing and suspending the innocent
intruder alert initiate security
protocol [ __ ] more than
see if there's a way to take them all
out at once
you're not gonna get through this door
okay you might as well give up because
i've hidden the key somewhere
there's another way though he said to go
keys in his office
school is closed
search him no no get away from me
come on we gotta find the brass the
protector of the brass key will never
surrender
intruder alert
so
where's your hall pass
i'm butters the merciful of the well
by the hammer of
i'm sorry
oh boy
ah
so
so
oh we can't get here without the silver
key
come on we got to find the brass key
oh
so
well i'm flattered you thought of me but
i wouldn't even know where to begin
why that just be silly
that just be silly
well i can only hear you need someone
who can chime
oh wow boobies must have
must touch
i'm taking fire
hey gingers your hearts are as black as
your noses are brown you can take the
brass key from my cold dead hands
you can take the brass key from my cold
dead hands
school is closed you can take the brass
key from my call dead hands
we can work this out
by the hammer of better
we'll see if it works
more officers down we're taking heavy
casualties out here
damn it you hallway monitors need to
stop playing around he's got the brass
key
he's some kind of dragonborn now look
this is detention time
not time to play dungeons and dragons
and besides he's never going to get
inside here because to open the door you
need the gold key and the only way to
get the gold key is by getting the
silver key
okay which even if he has a brass key he
still hasn't made it past the boss level
okay you found the brass key yeah
he's here guard the key
you're just making it harder on yourself
dude you [ __ ] your pants
you'll never escape the long arm of
counselor maggie's just you [ __ ] your
pants
every step you take is another 10
demerits
forget the key protect the front lines
well lucky there was a box of fireworks
just sitting there
you lawbreakers make me
well sick kid looks hurt pretty bad
dude you [ __ ] your pants
i'm taking fire
oh
your word is the command my lord
don't be afraid to ask for help from
your friends
your word is the command commandment
lord don't be afraid to ask for help
from your friends
your word is the command my lord
oh
hey oh don't forget the key hey oh don't
forget the key
your word is that don't be afraid to ask
for help from your friends
yes sir yeah there you go buddy
thanks i thought i was a goddard there
were too many of them they were too
strong
their hair too red maybe you could take
the silver key and find the goal key
you can succeed where i have failed free
matches prisoners
i sure hope the gold key is in there or
else the quest for the silver key has
been all for nothing
be careful juice bag this is mackie's
lair one wrong step and we could end up
in detention
the gold key no human has ever laid
hands on it before
let's hope it holds the power to unlock
the cafeteria door
that's far enough intruder where's your
hall pass
no hall pass then it's time to write you
a referral
oh yeah that's the buzz good luck
fighting the bars
okay you still think this is a game
young man
deadly fourth is authorized
ow
by the hammer fetish
i'm sorry
that wasn't so bad
oh
so
ah
i remember your glue
ah
[ __ ]
so
damn you cried
thanks for busting me out kid who are
you
what's your name
oh well i'm heading to koopa keep see
you there i guess
bye
wow
gentlemen thanks to the new kid our
entire army is assembled
it is my belief that the new kid
deserves to rank up in level
to honor his efforts he will no longer
be called douchebag
new kid i hereby dub the sir douchebag
congratulations
but now it is time for us to take back
that which is rightfully ours
a carrier raven has come with news that
the stick of truth has not yet been
taken to the elven forest
it is in the possession of the bard
oh god not the bard the bart is a level
10 draw wealth who can use magic
to enchant and destroy his enemies
are you ready to continue your training
then make haste to the training grounds
i'm going to teach you how to use a
ranged magic attack
it's not easy but being able to cup a
spell from a distance can save you in
battle
allow me to demonstrate
yeah let me show you one more time watch
closely
yeah you see how it works
now you try way back from where you're
standing cut the magic and throw it at
your opponent
yes yes but now let us see how you fare
against a real opponent
hey hey maggie's in magazine could you
come help us with something
don't touch it yes oh hey scott could
you um spar with douchebag real quick
he's going to try a new move
unkai now douchebag come spell
dude that was sweet you threw that [ __ ]
right in scott's face
all right scott go back to your post
thank you
use it wisely in battle douchebag and
never on a man's boss
if the carrier ravens are correct the
bard is hiding out at the end of the
giggling donkey
we must find him before he's able to
take the stick back to the oven forest
let us find the boat and bring him to
justice make haste to the giggling
donkey